alors le coup de coeur du ciné cette
semaine est instruit heure espagnole une
fois n'est pas coutume qui s'appelle
l'homme aux mille visages que vous
pourrez découvrir en version originale
dans nos salles cette semaine
alors l'intrigué est assez complexe je
vais pas trop la décrire mais c'est
l'histoire d'un ex agent secret qui est
embauché par le gouvernement espagnol
s'est inspiré de l'histoire vraie pour
démêler une affaire de faux et usage de
faux etc etc
cet ex agent va se venger du
gouvernement qui l'employait et va faire
tomber complètement gouvernement ce film
a été réalisé par alberto rodriguez
déjà auteur du très remarqué la isla
minima qu'on a pu découvrir à quelques
années second coup de coeur c'est une
rencontre qui aura lieu vendredi à 20h30
au ciné cette autour du film corporate
nous aurons le plaisir de rencontrer
nicolas fleurot qui n'est autre que le
scénariste du film qui viendra discuter
avec le public vendredi soir de ce film
corporate qui raconte on va dire les
difficultés dans une entreprise la
pression etc etc
rendez vous vendredi soir à 20h30 aussi
les c'est avec lui que l'afrique
qu'est ce que tu fous avec l'inspection
du travail j'essaye de m'en sortir ok
c'est parce que c'est seulement tu sais
pas qui suit